let's talk today about Biden omics
President Joe Biden giving a speech
yesterday in Chicago where he very
accurately and precisely dismantles the
trickle-down trash of the American right
wing of the last quite frankly 40 years
and it is actually getting to the point
you know not every president gets an
omics named after them we know about
Reaganomics certainly some people have
talked about clintonomics but there was
no bushonomics there was no Obama omics
or Obama economics as the term may be
whatever call it what you want the point
here is that President Joe Biden
whatever you think of the guy personally
whatever you think about Hunter Biden's
documents or Joe Biden's newly announced
sleep apnea which I will cover I have no
interest in covering up Joe Biden's
sleep apnea and his CPAP machine but
we'll get to that later whatever you
think about it we have a very
interesting economic situation where
despite continued claims from
Republicans that we are on the brink of
disaster
when you actually look at the Western
countries that the U.S Compares itself
to regularly we've seen more job
creation and lower inflation under Joe
Biden with just about every economic
indicator looking very strong and here
is indeed Joe Biden yesterday in Chicago
saying what many of us have known for a
long time trickle down economics the
idea that you give tax cuts to the rich
and then those benefits trickle down to
everybody else it sounds so stupid when
you say it because it's been so widely
debunked that it doesn't work because it
is a fundamental break of the economic
theory that has failed America's middle
class for decades now it's called
trickle-down economics fundamental
economics trickle down the idea was it's
believe that we should cut taxes for the
wealthy and big corporations and I know
some big corporations there's more
corporations in Delaware Incorporated
than every other state in the Union
combined
I want them to do well but I'm tired of
waiting for the trickle down
yeah it just never seems to trickle down
and listen if it is not
how can I say this I understand
most people would love for tax policy to
be such that they pay less that's a
normal thing even when I file my taxes
as someone who believes that to have a
functioning country we need a truly
progressive tax system when I actually
go and file my taxes of course I have
that moment where I go I would love to
keep more of my money that's not what's
wrong but then when you think okay but
this isn't just about me this is about
policy this is about how to run a
country this is how we have enough money
to do the things that rich developed
countries are able to do and should do
you realize that this trickle-down stuff
doesn't work now Joe Biden actually
spoke quite a bit about
um the economic indicators that he pays
attention to and you all know I don't
like to play these games with oh the
labor participation rate or or all debt
and deficit I just kind of tell it to
you like it is Joe Biden Acts actually
has a great thing going on if you are
president and you want to make the case
that the economy is good he actually has
the data on his side and the statistics
on his side I know we couldn't go back
to the same failed policies when I ran
so I came in office determine and change
the economic direction of this country
to move from trickle-down economics to
it everyone on Wall Street Journal and
Financial Times began to call vynomics I
didn't come up with the name right
I really did I now claim it but they're
the ones who use the first I got asked
by a press person this morning going
down the helicopter in Washington why
when I asked about bidenomics a long
time you said you didn't know what it
was
I said I didn't name it by Anonymous I
didn't realize the economist in the Wall
Street Journal did but I think it's a
plan that I'm happy to call binomics
[Applause]
and guess what
Dynamics is working
endemic is Raging and our economy was
reeling Supply chains are broken
millions of people unemployed hundreds
of thousands of small business on the
verge of closing after so many had
already closed literally hundreds of
thousands on the verge of closing today
the U.S has the highest economic growth
rate leading the world economies since
the pandemic the highest in the world
and of course that is among the
countries that share sort of our level
of development Joe Biden also by the way
hitting Republicans for now taking
credit for the very infrastructure bill
they opposed including mentioning
specifically Tommy tubber Bill
tuberville who the hell knows
there's no one's surprise
let's bring along some converts yep
people strenuously opposed voting
against it when we have had this going
on they were this was going to bankrupt
America
well there's a guy named tuberville from
Alabama center from Alabama who
announced a strongly opposed legislation
now he's healing his passage here's what
he said
quote it's great to see Alabama receive
critical funds to boost ongoing
Broadband efforts
[Applause]
all right and then Joe Biden making the
sign of the cross there so listen
um
I have no window you know you guys you
know me by now I have no interest in
gaslighting anybody here
um to some degree we were going to see
job recovery during this four-year
stretch
as we came out of covid and as Jobs lost
during covid were were recovered but
that's not all that we're seeing there
are millions of additional jobs there to
some degree the economic indicators that
we are seeing only have a little bit to
do with who's president of the United
States but the point here is what we
were told was that Joe Biden was going
to destroy the economy
and in fact the economy despite its
continued problems of inequality and
wages aren't as high as they should be
and all these different things is quite
an economy and so by Dynamics has
delivered results to the extent that we
believe the president has something to
do with how the economy is doing 13
million jobs added nearly 800 000 in
manufacturing it was Trump who said I'll
bring back manufacturing the clean
energy uh sector doing extraordinarily
well construction is improving strongest
growth since the pandemic of any
western-rich country on a number of
areas and and I've talked about all of
these little details before and it
really adds up to a big story
bionomics lowering costs for Working
Families in a number of different areas
we now see inflation down for 11 months
in a row the child tax credit expanded
under Biden's American Rescue plan has
reduced the number of kids in poverty
significantly reduce child health care
costs no one of these things is a
miracle but all of these little things
do add up we then had the bipartisan
infrastructure bill so we're finally
going to get some of those improvements
to roads and bridges and ports and
airports airports and Broadband it's not
going to be what so many other countries
have you look at Broadband in South
Korea you look at a train travel in
Europe but we're not there we're not
there we have a long way to go but at
least we're making some progress so we
do now have this thing called bidenomics
and it includes actually working to
strength strengthen the middle class
reducing inequality a little bit setting
raising the low bar below which we say
we don't need to let anybody fall below
this bar and doing it by investing where
it makes sense clean energy renewable
technology uh safer technology
all of these different things so we
don't
praise Biden for being solely
responsible for all of these economic
indicators there is a macro economic
reality that is bigger than the United
States but within that Within These this
group of countries uh oecd Rich Western
development Nations however you want to
slice and dice it within that group the
United States is doing particularly well
it's not just an economic plan really
it's more of a vision that includes
uh it includes I don't want to say
equality But it includes trying to write
some of the unbalanced circumstances
that the last 40 Years of attempts from
the trickle-downers uh has has created
and to that extent it's hard not to see
it as a success we're going to continue
watching the numbers there's still
plenty of time left in this uh
presidential term of Joe Biden to see it
go in a different direction but it is
really tough to argue with the results
so far